[Musique]
attrape l'association five en 78 fondé
par marc le faux locke permet aux petits
comme aux grands de s'immerger dans la
musique rock'n'roll qu'ils soient
adultes ou enfants
il plonge tous dans l'univers mythique
des beatles et des rolling stones
on essaye de comment dire
de faire de faire et de faire accéder à
la culture on va dire des enfants des
ados et même des adultes parce que on
est comme le journal de tintin on a de
2,6 même jusqu'à 77 ans son principe
c'est quand même essentiellement des
cours collectifs même à deux ou à trois
passes et - faisant on va dire c'est
moins difficile on peut plus
ça va se faire dans le temps il donne
beaucoup et puis le besoin de
transmission aussi voilà transmettre son
goût de la muse et transmettre voilà la
culture aussi voilà le plaisir des
instruments sont mis à disposition pour
les adhérents provenant de brocante
sites d'occasion ou de connaissances
marque le faux locke est un
professionnel de la récupération
ça fait des dizaines d'années qu'ils se
constituent une collection d'instruments
et qu'il les met à la disposition des
enfants
tiens je crois qu'un truc qui pourrait
être intéressée pour ton association
pendent lenovo nec s'il est arrivé là
après le reste on achète d'occasion
brocante ans j'ai commencé à accumuler
beaucoup depuis 2004 2005 rentrent en
préparant la suite de l'après collège
gratuit pour les enfants et seulement 15
euros par an pour les adultes
l'association taillevent 78 vous
embarquera dans son univers